hey everyone what's up I'm Ilana welcome
to my youtube channel I decided to bring
back a video series that I did a little
while ago which is called highlights why
basically I will surmise the past month
of games and geek culture and talk about
some of my favorite things - my least
favorite things in a really funky style
so today we're gonna be talking about
May 2016 which had Uncharted overwatch
Civil War x-men so first up I guess
let's talk about uncharted 4 that came
out at the start of the month and was
really really good in my opinion it's so
hard after playing through the trilogy
and maybe even just by virtue of Naughty
Dog being incredibly good writers and
hiring very good voice actors it's so
hard not to care about the characters in
Uncharted I care so much about Nathan
and Sully and Elena and I think that was
like a really big drawing part for me
was seeing how everyone turned out at
the end of that game really kept me
excited about it I think it has some
high points and some low points I didn't
enjoy the combat a whole lot and I
thought what some of the platforming was
pretty repetitive I think that's
especially emphasized by the fact that
the characters themselves acknowledge
that it's repetitive I feel like if your
characters are saying oh I have to do
this again your players are probably
thinking the same thing but I feel like
there's no way that you could write
something like Nathan Drake saying I got
gravel up my butt from doing this so
much because there's a lot of butt
sliding in uncharted fall there's no way
that you write that line in and don't
think oh the fact that we're writing
this means this is repetitive but even
that marci their repetitive stuff didn't
really bother me I did feel like the
game dragged on in Sutton Potts
I guess just particularly towards the
end to avoid spoiler territory it was
basically just like go here oh wait no
go here oh wait no go here oh wait one
more time go here it was just a really
dragged on climax because you kept
thinking you weren't gonna get to the
end and then the end had moved and you
have to keep chasing the end and it's
just a really odd way to do a climax but
I think my favorite part of the game was
Madagascar the cocche sequence that we
saw
at e3 I think Austria was probably the
highlight of the whole game to me that
was so so well done and high action and
just ridiculous and exciting and awesome
intense it was really good it's also a
freaking stunning game and there's some
really nice call backs to Nathan Drake's
childhood which I love every single one
of those so I still stand by naughty dog
being some of the best storytellers in
the entire games industry I think I
would have enjoyed Uncharted a little
bit more if it were just slightly
shorter would they just cuz some of the
fat cut off but for the most part I
really really enjoyed it next up Captain
America Civil War some of what was great
and I say that as a person who read the
Civil War comics and I'm very passionate
about the Civil War comics it doesn't
entirely parallel those comics and I
think that's fine I think you're setting
yourself an unrealistic expectation if
you go into a comic book movie expecting
it to be the exact same as the comic
that doesn't happen we know that by now
Spiderman was know best it was so good
and believably spider-man just to a tee
I love that version of spider-man I
think actually Civil War probably did
the best job of betraying each of the
individual characters in the film than
any of the previous films my biggest
complaint or actually not a complaint
just a thing about Civil War was I think
it was very easy to consume it was just
you know fun kind of dumb entertainment
I went in there wanting it to have more
depth than it did have so you know
walking out of that movie it was like it
didn't really feel like it impacted that
universe very heavily I didn't feel a
whole lot because of it it was mostly
just exciting to watch and that's
totally fine I think that's not a bad
thing
but Captain America Winter Soldier is
still my favorite Marvel movie for sure
next up we had doom I haven't played
very much of doom because I haven't had
time just yet because I've been playing
so much overwatch but from what I have
played I think Doom is kind of shallow
but very fun a lot of my friends really
loved it so I guess it gets a lot better
than the first few hours which is all I
played which didn't really grab me all
that much but I didn't dislike it
so we have [ __ ] overwatch
I love of watch I almost never get
really hooked on online multiplayer
games pretty much never I haven't been
this addicted to an online multiplayer
experience since Gears of War one the
best thing about it is each character is
so different and has to be played
differently and certain parts of certain
maps have to be played with different
characters or not have to it's just that
you constantly have to adjust and maybe
with the way that you play a certain
character it won't walk as well and an
open part of the map as it does in a
closed part of the map so you just
shifting constantly for me I never feels
like a dumb run-and-gun kind of game it
always feels like I have to calculate
everything that I'm doing and pay
attention to what I'm doing and every
time that I die I feel like it's my
fault like I know that I did something
wrong and I learned from it so at the
moment I'm favoring Farah and machree I
love playing Sarah it took me a really
long time to figure out how to play her
at Fuss I just hated her until I figured
out that you kind of have to play the
like quick meaning you just fed a jet
pack a lot so you're constantly moving
and trying to be really erratic and high
as much as you can so you just aim down
that's the easiest way to get Splash
Damage
to get less technical people haven't
played up watch want to know if they
might want to play I don't know it is a
shooter a team-based shooter but it's
basically it feels different to a
regular yes in that agency hero shooter
meaning the game is driven by the
characters in it you're not just playing
miscellaneous dude with slightly
different loadout you are playing a
character with a personality and a
background and accent and catchphrases
and a totally different play style to
every other character who can count up
other characters what next Disney
infinity closed avalanche software who I
actually went and visited in Utah a
couple of months ago fully clothed and
that's shocking to me when I was there I
had no
that this would be happening I had
absolutely I just never would have
guessed everyone was talking about the
next thing they were walking on and
really awkwardly trying to get around
what they could I couldn't talk about
when I was asking them interview
questions meaning I think these guys had
a Content plan for several years after
when they shut down I don't think this
is a reflection of toys to life failing
because the Disney infinity fig is sold
incredibly well I'll leave a link below
to the documentary that I worked on and
I also put together a gallery of every
single Disney infinity toy ever made if
you want to look through that hangout
gorgeous so skyline has also announced a
new game which I were to preview all of
that skyline is imaginate us I really
like Skyland is despite it being cool
kids I wait and we like it as basically
like a Diablo or gauntlet but just kind
of easier and I mean I could talk about
that for long but I'll leave a link to
my preview of that one below as well and
last but not least I guess I'll talk
about x-men apocalypse x-men apocalypse
is pretty bad I didn't think that it was
as bad as Batman V Superman and I know
there are a lot of people who disagree
with me on this but I thought Batman V
Superman was awful
x-men apocalypse was was a little bit
better it started off really interesting
I think the main a bad guy and it is
interesting and has an interesting
premise there was some cool visuals but
my biggest problem with it was just the
dial up was atrocious it was just so so
so cringe-worthy and there was also love
stung didn't make sense
it's the most of my may 2016 I'm sure
there was some other stuff in there but
those are basically just my highlights
I'd love to know what you guys thought
of each of the things that I spoke about
here and obviously this month is III so
there's many tons to talk about I really
want those console remiss to one get
cleared up and there's a lot of
announcements that I'm really excited
about so III is gonna be crazy and I
guess that is it for me today I'm sorry
this video looks so bad I'm currently in
Montreal Canada I didn't bring my camera
with me so this is on my webcam but I
hope that it you know turns out fine for
your viewing pleasure and I will see you
guys next time bye